[Música]
hoy en el debate de France 24 vamos a
poner la lupa en Israel y en los
territorios palestinos varios hechos han
ocurrido en las últimas semanas así lo
hemos reportado aquí en France 24 y por
eso vale la pena hacer un análisis del
panorama general en esa región primero
Comencemos por el nuevo gobierno de
Israel si muchos pensaban que los
anteriores gobiernos liderados por el
Primer Ministro Benjamín netanyahu eran
conservadores su opinión tal vez cambió
al ver la coalición y el gabinete más
reciente para muchos El listón de un
gobierno conservador pasó a ser un
gobierno de extrema derecha o de
extremismo Y tomó un nuevo significado
debido a la tendencia que tiene
políticamente hablando entre sus
ministros hay varias figuras de la
escena política israelí muy reconocidos
que llaman mucho la atención por ejemplo
y Tamara que es un ministro y también
besalel
que son considerados de extrema derecha
y que han defendido el retiro de los
palestinos de los territorios donde se
encuentran hay algunos sectores no lo
digo yo no lo dice France 24 lo dicen
los analistas y expertos en este tema
que hay sectores dentro del país que lo
han tildado por defender una supuesta
limpieza étnica en esa región es así hay
argumentos para hacer ese tipo de
señalamientos Ya lo vamos a ver y lo
vamos a consultar con nuestros invitados
ese gobierno tan conservador hace temer
sobre el rumbo que pueda tomar entonces
Israel en sus políticas internas en sus
políticas hacia los palestinos y también
sobre ese papel fundamental que juega el
país en la región de medio oriente y en
el escenario internacional vamos a
analizar también entonces cuál va a ser
ese rumbo que va a tomar el país de
hecho ya lo vemos con algunas decisiones
que han tomado por ejemplo las medidas
punitivas impuestas por Israel contra
Palestina Por qué pues veamos porque
justamente en la asamblea general de la
ONU en una resolución que publicaron le
solicitó a la Corte Internacional de
Justicia una opinión sobre la ocupación
israelí de los territorios palestinos
las decisiones que se toman allí son
simplemente sugerencias no tienen que
llevarse a cabo y está pendiente por
conocerse esa opinión Israel rechazó
esta medida y Palestina la calificó como
una victoria diplomática dos caras
completamente diferentes de la moneda
días después Israel anunció sanciones
entre las que hay algunas sanciones
financieras por eso cerca de 40 países
respaldaron las declaraciones y
denunciaron estas represalias que ha
tomado Israel contra Palestina en los
últimos días a raíz de este pedido que
hizo ante la organización de Naciones
Unidas entonces para el análisis y para
comenzar ya con el programa En este
gobierno de corte conservador de extrema
derecha como se le quiera Llamar
representa entonces una amenaza para la
estabilidad del país para la estabilidad
con palestinos y para la estabilidad de
esa región Qué papel debe asumir
entonces la comunidad internacional para
dar garantías en cuanto a los derechos
para los palestinos que están recibiendo
Allí están recibiendo allí y están
recibiendo sanciones por parte de Israel
están viendo un endurecimiento de las
políticas de Israel a qué precio este
nuevo gobierno que plan tiene entonces
para el conflicto con Palestina Qué plan
tiene para su política exterior Hoy
entonces veremos en detalle la situación
en medio oriente en particular la
situación entre Israel y Palestina tema
difícil de analizar pero que vamos a
tomar con pinzas y con lupa para
analizar algunos puntos en específico
para conversar entonces sobre este tema
hemos invitado a Gabriel ventas gal él
es analista político especializado en
temas relacionados con medio oriente se
conecta desde la Ciudad de Jerusalén y
desde la ciudad de Bogotá en Colombia
saludamos a Alexander Montero él es
consejero político de la embajada de
Palestina ante el gobierno colombiano
también docente universitario
especializado por supuesto en temas
relacionados con medio oriente ustedes
nuestros televidentes les recuerdo que
también hacen parte de este debate
ustedes ya lo saben pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral el debate f-24 no
olviden y ya para terminar que todos los
contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
pues comienzo entonces dándole la
bienvenida a Gabriel en la Ciudad de
Jerusalén Gabriel Gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa y Comencemos
analizando este nuevo gobierno de Israel
Qué plan tiene este gobierno para el
futuro del país para las relaciones
internacionales y si lo debemos
calificar como un gobierno
extremadamente conservador o como muchos
han dicho como de extrema derecha
sí sin duda es un gobierno conservador
Más que nada porque el mapa político de
Israel se divide en cinco ejes y la
coalición actual de Israel está
conformada por partidos políticos que no
le han declarado un boicottaneado la
situación de Israel no ha cambiado
demasiado porque en el medio oriente
actual se vive un proceso de aceptación
cada vez mayor hacia Israel Dentro de
pocos probable que nos volvamos a
comunicar pero esta vez para hablar
sobre un acuerdo de paz entrará vía
Saudita Israel mientras que eso ocurre
el tema palestino queda relegado en la
agenda del medio oriente y es un tema
que a pocos le importan
y por lo tanto la situación actual de
ellos es problemática de los palestinos
son vistos por su propia población como
un gobierno corrupto el de la autoridad
Palestina y en el caso del
enfrentamiento con Israel es visto como
Israel como un gobierno en el cual le
queda pocos días de vida porque a más
muda vas como la autoridad Palestina hoy
La verdad es que tiene poco control
incluso sobre ciudades palestinas O sea
que la pregunta Central es hasta qué
punto es relevante el gobierno de la
autoridad Palestina para un medio
oriente en donde gobierna la calle
Palestina Jamás Los Guardianes de las
guarida de los Leones en muchas ciudades
el frente popular para liberación de
Palestina yo creo que lamentablemente el
gobierno palestino hoy en día es un
gobierno que prácticamente no existe y
preguntémosle ahora Alexander La otra
cara de la moneda desde la perspectiva
Palestina como Ven a este nuevo gobierno
de Israel como ya lo hemos definido Un
gobierno bastante conservador con
algunas figuras que llaman mucho la
atención en la escena política de Israel
y que también ponen la lupa de la
comunidad internacional en torno a
algunas decisiones que ellos ya han
tomado en el pasado o posiciones que han
tomado en el pasado frente a temas por
ejemplo el tema palestino
Santiago Buenas tardes un gran saludo a
todos los televidentes también
realmente es preocupante y esta
preocupación la comparte no solamente
Palestina sino la comparte buena medida
la Unión Europea y el mismo Estados
Unidos estamos acá para hablar del
gobierno de Israel no el gobierno
Palestina al menos en una primera opción
y este gobierno de Israel este nuevo
gobierno Israel prende alarmas
justamente por estar Atrapado en un
discurso religioso más allá incluso a la
derecha yo siempre he planteado que este
gobierno israelí ni siquiera es de
derecha porque realmente se parten dos
tendencias quienes están a favor quien
Están en contra y en esta discusión
estos partidos minoritarios
religiosos extremistas
que juntan la religión y la política y
las armas con un discurso supremacista y
con un discurso también xenófobo han
tenido o han ganado más bien un
protagonismo para que el neta ya pudiera
lograr la mayoría en la nese son
partidos pequeños pero muy importantes y
eso lo saben ellos justamente
si hacemos un recorrido muy rápido
tenemos básicamente
organizaciones terroristas que al menos
de inhibir se le relaciona incluso con
el asesinato del Primer Ministro bisagra
viene en Israel y que gracias a ese
poder que han logrado en estas
elecciones han logrado dos ministerios
supremamente importantes el de finanzas
y el de seguridad nacional de seguridad
nacional es crítico porque básicamente
estamos diciendo que
la Marvin este que fue terrorista en el
pasado este que anda armado
a aldeas palestinas este que ha liderado
movimientos que gritan muerte a los
árabes este va a controlar a las fuerzas
de ocupación israelíes dentro de
Jordania entonces llega a ser tal la
preocupación que generan estos estos
ministros que el mismo Ven y ganas
dentro de Israel los mismos líderes de
la policía Israel el mismo Estados
Unidos de Israel el mismo Estados Unidos
está tremendamente preocupado por el
rumbo que tome Israel en este momento
Alexander continuó con usted para hacer
la ronda la inversa ya le doy la palabra
a Gabriel Quiero preguntarle a ver Esta
es la opinión en torno y el temor que
hay entonces en torno a este nuevo
gobierno pero que ese tema Entonces por
el futuro de Palestina con este gobierno
respaldando las decisiones que se tomen
en Israel
Bueno aquí hay varios escenarios que se
abren justamente eso y se ponen sobre la
mesa el primero que ante la crisis de
pronto popularidad que pueda tener
entallado la crisis legal que tiene el
mal manejo le debe dar la reforma
judicial posiblemente de tanyahu quiera
apalancarse en un discurso religioso
apoyado en estos partidos y generar un
distractor y ese distractor puede ser un
una escala de pensiones entre Israel y
Palestina el segundo escenario puede ser
básicamente que estos partidos Sabiendo
poder que tienen exijan leyes cada vez
más restrictivas frente a los palestinos
les importa muy poco
Las investigaciones que las Naciones
Unidas han hecho los informes que han
sacado recientemente
Este cambio de posición histórica de la
ONU Donde ha calificado Israel
claramente como una como un régimen de
aparte y frente a los palestinos les
importa muy poco y básicamente en su
discurso lo que quieren es ahondar esta
esta posición abierta
y en consecuencia cualquier escenario va
a ser abiertamente absolutamente
preocupante para los palestinos no
solamente los palestinos para todo el
medio oriente Gabriel entendamos ahora
la la posición desde la otra cara de la
moneda son temores infundidos
o hay indicios claros de este nuevo
gobierno que este tipo de situaciones
que describe Alexander pueden llegar a
suceder o que hay
algún tipo de plan en donde se pueda
llevar a cabo algún tipo de acciones que
permita este escenario que está
describiendo Alexander
no no ese es sin duda el análisis que
acabamos de escuchar es de alguien que
no vive en el medio oriente que
lamentablemente no escucha lo que yo
escucho en árabe los líderes árabes no
están preocupados por todo lo que acaba
de escribir y si los líderes árabes no
están preocupados Entonces nos deberían
llamar la atención con respecto a la
fiabilidad o a la seriedad de laálisis
que acabamos de escuchar
la diferencia fundamental entre el
gobierno anterior y el gobierno actual
erradica lo siguiente la autoridad
Palestina como gobierno dedica el 11% de
su presupuesto a pagar la terroristas
que asesinaron judíos y además Los
acuerdos de oslo definieron que no
podían los palestinos ir e intentar
solucionar por vía internacional el
futuro de el proceso de paz y lo están
haciendo Y además el proceso de oslo
también decía que los palestinos tenían
que combatir de forma efectiva contra el
terrorismo destino y en vez de
combatirlo lo alientan lo alientan por
ejemplo con una metodología llamada Java
pueden buscar ustedes por internet un
montón de discursos desde autoridad
parecida que incitan al terrorismo el
que fomentan el terrorismo la diferencia
con el gobierno anterior con el gobierno
actual es que el gobierno anterior podía
convivir con esa incitación a la
violencia Palestina sin emitir sanciones
el gobierno actual que es más
conservador dice no puede ser que los
palestinos sigan haciendo lo que están
haciendo sin pagar un precio es la
diferencia entre unos y otros si tú me
preguntas a mí muchos líderes árabes
especialmente mucho los líderes sunitas
están hartos de los palestinos hartos yo
convivo con los palestinos mucho porque
trabajo con ellos Ayer me contaron un
chiste dice que llamaba la esposa de
mahmuda Baz al presidente palestino y le
dice entraron a casa a robarnos y el
presidente palestino le dice no puede
ser porque tengo todos los ministros
conmigo en mi habitación fíjate los
propios palestinos están hartos de este
gobierno corrupto y por lo tanto la
diferencia política ante un gobierno y
otro Santiago simplemente que uno quiere
devolverle a la incitación Palestina de
alguna manera para dominar esa
encitación o ese esa búsqueda para
incitar el terrorismo y otro simplemente
puede convivir con ellos Gabriel usted
menciona Palestina debe pagar un precio
Cuál es ese precio
No simplemente el precio del problema
sabes cuál es Santiago es un problema de
dilema para Israel porque la autoridad
Palestina es un gobierno es
esencialmente muy débil que
prácticamente no gobiernan un montón de
ciudades que ni siquiera gobierna la
franja de gaza donde le hizo un golpe de
estado jamás el tema del gobierno
israelí es como la incitación Palestina
es constante si tú debilitas demasiado a
la autoridad Palestina al presidente
abaz o al sucesor el la alternativa a
los palestinos es el jamás que es mucho
más islamista todavía entonces cómo
haces tú para intentar que no insisten
al terrorismo y que paguen un precio de
alguna manera y no debilitar lo
suficiente como para que dejen de
existir y en su reemplazo venga el jamás
Ese es el dilema central que tiene el
gobierno israelí ahora
paso a preguntarle a Alexander por la
posición de Palestina en el escenario
internacional mencionaba yo que incluso
en Palestina calificaron como una
victoria diplomática a nivel
internacional ese logro que las Naciones
Unidas le pidiera la Corte Internacional
de Justicia una opinión sobre la
ocupación de Israel de algunos
territorios palestinos en cuanto al
posicionamiento internacional Palestina
se mantiene sólida se mantiene con
respaldo internacional o este respaldo
poco a poco se va desvaneciendo debido a
la coyuntura que hay internacionalmente
la guerra en Ucrania los conflictos que
hay abiertos en otros escenarios y que
este conflicto en en medio oriente pues
ya lleva muchísimas décadas está abierto
desde hace mucho tiempo y la posibilidad
de un diálogo y una solución no está tan
a la vuelta de la esquina como lo
estamos entendiendo con este análisis
Bueno me gustaría ir por partes de
pronto iniciar por algo que Gabriel o
Hernán que realmente se llama
inicia y ese descalificar al adversario
descalificar al al en este caso al
contradictor el argumenta que mi
posición no es una posición real porque
yo no vivo en Palestina
Lamento realmente
la utilización de este argumento
básicamente mi experiencia académica y
ejercicio profesional y mis trabajos de
campo y mi estadía en el terreno me
hacen conocer a Palestina la ocupación
tanto o más porque Hernán o Gabriel lo
puede conocer de hecho es curioso porque
Gabriel
lo conoce desde la perspectiva del
ocupante hay que recordar que él como
argentino vive de hecho en una colonia y
que esta quedó absolutamente plasmada en
la respuesta anterior es muy importante
y aquí quiero recabar también lo que
Santiago mencionaba esa frase pagar el
precio Esa frase pagar el precio es la
frase de colonos extremistas es más
había un grupo terrorista dentro de los
colores israelíes que se hacía llamar
así pagar el precio valdría la pena
Resaltar la coincidencia el
planteamiento de Gabriel ventasal y la
la propuesta estos grupos extremistas en
el pasado han incendiado casas y han
incinerado palestinos bebés dentro de
dentro de estos muertos entonces la
ocupación es el foco del problema tiene
claramente una víctima y un victimario
el victimarios no no puede echarle la
culpa en una situación de ocupación a la
víctima y para esto la el contexto
internacional es fenomenal si uno pone
en perspectiva el conflicto o la
ocupación más bien de Israel sobre
Palestina y la compara con lo que está
ocurriendo en Ucrania el despropósito
que nos propone en este momento Gabriel
es prácticamente acusar a Ucrania de
querer defenderse de Rusia así de
sencillo Entonces
es claro es importante es imperativo a
partir del hecho que esto es una
ocupación militar muy similar en varios
aspectos a lo que está ocurriendo entre
Rusia ahora bien entrando de lleno una
pregunta es Clara la reacción de la
comunidad internacional tanto de
izquierda de derecha de Centro la misma
Alemania Hace unos días esta semana
publicada una nota muy interesante sobre
las hipotéticas crisis que se pueden
avecinar entre las relaciones justamente
por este enfoque de este gobierno
bastante radical extremista
fundamentalista por demás en Israel hace
ver es que el mundo Cada vez más está
menos expuesto a esta retórica israelí
está menos expuesto a esta propaganda la
insisto ha ayudado para poner muchas
cosas en perspectiva y la propaganda
israelí de la cual Gabriel
un gran portal de propaganda Suramérica
maneja bastante bien entonces Estos
espacios se han cerrado y ese es el y
una muestra es justamente lo que pasó en
Naciones Unidas vamos a ver si la Corte
Internacional de Justicia reacciona Y si
a Israel le vale un pepino como pasó con
la opinión consultiva del muro ya hace
bastantes años donde la corte en pleno
dijo que el muro era ilegal no por ser
muro sino porque estaba dentro del suelo
palestino Israel le importó en la
arrogancia tradicional le ha importado
muy poco
Gabriel Cómo entender Entonces ese papel
de Israel en el escenario internacional
un país que goza con respaldo de grandes
potencias internacionales como por
ejemplo Estados Unidos la Unión Europea
pero que por ejemplo se niega a
respaldar justamente las sanciones que
la Unión Europea de Estados Unidos le
han impuesto a Rusia por la invasión de
la región del donbas en Ucrania rechaza
también ese acuerdo nuclear firmado en
el 2015 vende programas de espionaje a
diferentes países del mundo y que vende
armas a gobiernos totalitarios o
autoritarios como es el caso del
gobierno de azerbaiyán que es un gran
Aliado de Israel en el cáucaso y que en
este momento sus armas israelíes están
siendo usadas contra la población
Armenia en la región de nagorno caravaca
cómo entender ese ese desempeño de
Israel en el escenario internacional
tan errático digamos lo visto desde este
lado del Atlántico
Mira ante todo yo la verdad es que no
sabía que alguien sabía algo de sobre mi
vida personal Yo lamentablemente nunca
he leído ningún texto ni creo que
ninguna Universidad del mundo de primera
línea hayan leído un texto de este
supuesto académico pero como no voy a
entrar en temas personales porque
realmente
le Quiero ofrecer al público una
respuesta seria y no la mediocridad que
acabamos de escuchar ahora le quiero
decir lo siguiente mira en el medio
oriente hoy se divide en cuatro tipos de
fuerzas se divide en países chichitas en
países que apoyan el radicalismo
islámico pero que no hacen terrorismo
como Qatar y Turquía en movimientos
radicales islámicos como Isis al caída
jamás palestino islámica Palestina que
son movimientos que quieren imponer un
califato en el medio oriente y por otro
lado tenemos el cuarto grupo que son
países sunitas no radicales esos países
sunitas no radicales son los que están
haciendo un montón de pactos con Israel
la pregunta del millón Y por qué hacen
pacto con Israel por dos razones
fundamentales la primera es porque
Israel se ha convertido en una potencia
militar y una potencia económica y los
países unitas necesitan de ese apoyo
para poder detener al Principal enemigo
de la región que es Irán y por otro lado
porque tenemos un periodo post petrolero
en donde los países del medio ambiente
entienden tanto
qué es importante acercarse a occidente
y acercarse a una potencia tecnológica
como Israel por otro lado tu pregunta
para no hasta para tu pregunta Santiago
Isabel dilema serio Porque lo que ocurre
es que por un lado está colaborando con
hacer bailán porque hacer bailán va a
permitir y permite un posible ataque en
el futuro contra Irán que seguramente no
va a ser solo de Israel sino de pasar de
varios países unitas y por otro lado El
dilema Central es que la población
israelí apoya a Ucrania claramente y por
otro lado Israel tiene
condiciones frías con Rusia por un
problema que tenemos en Siria en donde
hay mucha presencia iraní en Siria pero
el país lo domina Rusia cada tanto
Israel ataca a Irán en suelo sirio para
alejarlo los rusos están de acuerdo con
eso y por tanto Israel quiere mantener
relación correcta con ambos países con
Ucrania y con Rusia entonces este dilema
es bastante no errático se puede
entender la situación política de Israel
a nivel regional a nivel internacional
de todas formas lo que te quiero decir
es que cada vez Israel está acercándose
a muchos países que antes nos parecía
desconocido o inimaginable más aún
Santiago me vas a llamar dentro de poco
para que hablemos sobre el pacto de paz
entre Israel y Arabia Saudita porque va
a ocurrir y mientras que esto ocurre
Lamentablemente el tema palestino va
siendo relegado porque la gran mayoría
del medio oriente está te vuelvo a decir
harto de los
alto del choriqueo constante de los
palestinos cuando son los mismos
palestinos los que incitan al terrorismo
los que hacen terrorismo y los que
maltratan su propia población Gabriel
continuó con usted Por qué pierde
prioridad este tema de los palestinos la
relación con Palestina cuando es un tema
de casa no es mejor tener la casa
organizada y luego mirar por fuera y
tratar de hacer este acercamiento con
Arabia Saudita que es un acercamiento
que hemos visto que ha venido fluyendo
en los últimos meses no solamente con
con Arabia Saudita sino con otros países
de del Golfo Pérsico
cuando no se tiene la casa completamente
organizada Por qué no apostar por
ordenar y arreglar este conflicto en vez
de estar mirando a otros países de la
región que en el pasado fueron sus
enemigos
sí sin duda Santiago sería lo ideal Lo
que pasa que el gobierno de Israel ya le
ofreció a los palestinos el 100% de
ciscordania en el acuerdo en el la
propuesta de paz de olmer del año 2008
le propuso completamente en la totalidad
de Jordania con un intercambio de
territorios de seis por ciento y también
le ofreció dividir Jerusalén e incluso
pensar en el la darle ciudadanía cien
mil palestinos lo que pasa es que
mientras que eso ocurre la autoridad
Palestina los palestinos y también
seguramente los oradores del lado
palestino dicen que ellos no quieren ese
terreno quieren la totalidad del estado
de Israel y la destrucción del estado de
Israel por eso hablan de 75 años de
ocupación no no quieren decir Jordania
quedan 75 años de ocupación el medio
oriente entiende la negativa Palestina y
mientras que la negativa Palestina
continúa Arabia Saudita necesita Israel
emiratos árabes necesita Israel los
países del medio oriente necesitan de
Israel y por lo tanto Sería bueno el
tema palestino pero para eso debe los
palestinos de jardín cita del terrorismo
y aceptar la existencia de un estado
Claro en el estado puede entender ese
punto Gabriel puede entender la posición
que tiene Israel frente a Rusia y el
conflicto en Ucrania lo que todavía no
me queda muy claro es porque tener esta
relación con el gobierno de alief en
azerbaiyán y permitir que con armas
israelíes asesinen a ciudadanos armenios
en el cáucaso eso todavía no queda claro
y se lo cuestiona la comunidad
internacional Alexander su opinión sobre
sobre esta posición que expresa Gabriel
sobre esta falta tal vez de obviamente
de diálogo si no no estaríamos
debatiendo sobre este conflicto
Qué opinión tiene sobre esta posición
bueno mire lo primero es una herramienta
recurrente de Gabriel cuando se siente
acorralado acusar al otro de mediocridad
de fanatismo de no conocer la realidad
como él la conoce pero reitero es
lamento y me parece bastante triste
este nivel de argumentación en un
espacio tan serio como este pero más
allá de eso
vale la pena insistir que Israel está
hoy viendo un proceso el cerramiento y
acercamiento muy importante
después el fin del periodo en Estados
Unidos la llegada del gobierno biden un
giro en Europa un giro en América la
misma guerra entre de Rusia y Ucrania ha
puesto Israel contra las cuerdas y le ha
cerrado muchísimos espacios esto incluso
quedó bastante bastante claro
con el cambio de posición de las
Naciones Unidas donde después de casi 50
años volvieron recabar las
características de apartate que tiene
Israel eso no lo está diciendo ningún
propalestino no lo está diciendo
Irán no lo está diciendo Ucrania no lo
está diciendo Rusia lo está diciendo las
Naciones Unidas
ahora es muy fácil desacreditar a las
Naciones Unidas desacreditar el comité
de Derechos Humanos de las Naciones
Unidas desacreditar el observador
especial que tiene la ONU para la
ocupación y en esto Israel es bastante
recurrente porque no le tiembla la voz
ni la mano para acusar de antisemita a
quien ellos consideren Pero la realidad
es que el mundo está enfrentando está
viendo cada vez más ese trasfondo Israel
Un gobierno que se debate entre los
Caprichos de netanyahu y el
fundamentalismo religioso Un gobierno
tiene mucho de parecido al Irán que
tanto critican Un gobierno que tiene
mucho desaparecido incluso
al monstruo del tanto criticaron
Justamente estaba Atrapado entre
discurso religioso extremistas
fundamentalistas xenófos homofóbicos y
sobre todo con una crisis institucional
tremendamente grande que para resolver
esa crisis terminan justamente ahondando
recabando en el tema palestino Gabriel
menciona que los palestinos lloriquean
ese lloriqueo tiene cansado a los árabes
Yo realmente como académico pido respeto
por el dolor de
por el dolor de las víctimas en general
es como si él estuviera diciendo que los
ucranianos lloriquean cuando se
defienden de Rusia o cuando ponen sobre
la mesa en la comuna internacional lo
que está haciendo Rusia contra ellos que
es una situación Exactamente igual o muy
parecida al menos entre lo que hace
Israel con Palestina y también Gabriel
para finalizar recurrió a una a una
herramienta muy interesante y es volver
a al refrito que es que los palestinos
quieren la destrucción Israel los
palestinos no quieren eso los palestinos
desde hace rato aceptaron a Israel
reconocieron al Estado de Israel los
palestinos lo que quieren es que
finalice la ocupación aquí valdría más
bien la pena preguntarle a Israel Por
qué la insistencia de Israel en no vivir
dentro de sus fronteras sino en vivir
ocupando el territorio del vecino O sea
si el día de mañana Israel eh benjivir a
netanyahu o Gabriel ventasal dicen que
la mitad de Francia es de Israel
entonces hay que hacerle caso los
franceses no pueden decir nada ni se
pueden oponer a eso porque es un
lloriqueo Entonces es una es una
manipulación realmente bastante profunda
de los argumentos y una una ñapa como
decimos aquí en Colombia El porqué de la
relación de los Países Árabes de algunos
Países Árabes no de todos con Israel sin
duda lo único que concuerdo con con
Gabriel Es que Arabia saudí muy
seguramente
va a normalizar relaciones con Israel
Pero eso no se trata de un tema
palestino se trata es por un elemento
clarísimo en el en el en el en las
relaciones internacionales que se llama
interés nacional lo que quiere decir es
que tanto emiratos árabes Marruecos
barren y en el futuro horarios van a
volver a mirar es a su interés nacional
sino a un interés es eso básica
Alexander Quiero preguntarle por la
unidad de Palestina y de este gobierno
hay un desgaste de este gobierno actual
hay una necesidad de un cambio de un
nuevo liderazgo de un nuevo rumbo de un
nuevo impulso a nivel político en la
autoridad Palestina para llevar esto por
un rumbo diferente por otro camino cómo
lo ve usted
mire en efecto hay una crisis en efecto
hay un desgaste en efecto Tendría que
haber ocurrido lecciones hace rato en
efecto hay una crítica generalizada
básicamente al liderazgo más moraz eso
es claro
Y eso tendrá que resolverse justamente
dentro de palestino las fuerzas
políticas palestinas van a tener que
llegar a un acuerdo donde se busque
nuevamente unas elecciones donde Israel
permita que los palestinos de Jerusalén
este ocupada puedan votar cosa que
Israel se ha negado hasta ahora
sí
permitan también eso y se logra un
diálogo político pero en efecto
Palestina tiene que resolver esta crisis
cuyo resultado democrático tiene que ser
aceptado por Israel cosa que no ocurrió
en las elecciones del 2006
Gabriel tengo que preguntarle ya para
este último bloque del programa por esas
manifestaciones de miles de personas en
diferentes ciudades de Israel
protestando en contra de esa reforma a
la justicia en Israel hay algunos
sectores allí que dicen que lo que está
sucediendo aquí es que de alguna forma
el Primer Ministro Benjamín es tratando
de blindarse de esas investigaciones que
hay por corrupción en su contra que
también muchos no se explican como una
persona que está siendo investigada por
este tipo de casos vuelve a participar
en un proceso electoral y queda ahora
como Primer Ministro de ese país cuando
está siendo investigado por diferentes
acusaciones de corrupción qué se puede
decir sobre esto
en este momento el nivel de poliarquía
de democracia en Israel es está en el
puesto 23 en el mundo casi igual que
Francia por tanto es un estado de
derecho y en los estados de derecho a
diferencia de Francia que al presidente
no se lo puede procesar en Israel sí se
lo puede procesar cuando están en
funciones pero no es culpable hasta que
no se Determine lo contrario el programa
de reformas es un programa que tiene
amplia por un lado apoyo en parte de la
población israelí y no respeta partidos
políticos hay varios temas que tiene que
ver con la reforma y te digo por ejemplo
dos la composición de la suprema corte
de justicia que es principalmente
universalista mientras que los
conservadores de este gobierno
consideran que tiene que ser más
igualitaria más representativa del
público tenemos un problema de lo que se
llama el principio de legalidad Y es que
cualquier persona puede hacer cualquier
juicio a otra persona sin que esté
implicado directamente y eso critica es
muy criticado sectores conservadores y
Tenemos también un principio de
razonabilidad muy extendido o sea los
jueces
cancelan anula anulan leyes del
parlamento en base a lo que consideran
que no es razonable todo esto ha creado
una pérdida de legitimidad de la
justicia y una democracia activa como
Israel e intenta replanteárselo y esas
son las discusiones que hay Yo entiendo
que hablar de democracia en medio
oriente Cuando tenemos vecinos como los
palestinos que la última elección en el
año 2005 una cadencia de cuatro años que
el primer que el presidente
Por supuesto que no llama elecciones no
llama elecciones porque pierde frente al
jamás y por lo tanto no va a llamar
nunca lecciones porque cuando estamos
hablando de una de una democracia como
le salí frente a un totalitarismo como
el palestino que está ciento nueve en el
mundo en el índice de democracia es
difícil convivir entre un sistema hay
otro sistema y por lo tanto también este
diálogo en este medio de comunicación
cuando hablamos de un país parecido a
Francia y otro país como Palestina muy
parecido a Corea del Norte Gabriel pero
rápidamente pero está está reforma no
debilita el papel de la Corte Suprema no
le da más poder al parlamento para poder
anular estas decisiones judiciales
simplemente por un voto de mayoría
simple incluso
tener un control sobre el nombramiento
de los jueces y de esto no reduce un
poco la independencia de las
instituciones porque para muchos
israelíes no lo digo yo no lo digo no lo
dice France 24 no lo decimos a título
personal justamente se está poniendo en
riesgo esa democracia en Israel que ha
sido ejemplo en la región
sí sin duda Santiago lo que ha ocurrido
es que la el poder judicial la suprema
corte de justicia ha sido acusada de
estar demasiado expansionista y ahora el
parlamento intenta de alguna manera
recuperar más o menos el balance no es
el único país en donde se propone que
los jueces sean nombrados por el poder
político de hecho en Estados Unidos
también lo es lo que estamos haciendo es
una discusión Porque algunos dicen que
se ha desbalanceado demasiado la
democracia israelí hacia una hacia un
poder demasiado extendido el poder
judicial y otros dicen que es preferible
ese poder en el poder judicial porque
nuestra democracia es tan fuerte que
necesitamos jueces que tengan mucho
poder y que son más confiables que los
políticos por eso lo que ocurre en la
actualidad Santiago bueno Gabriela
Alexander se nos acaba el tiempo es
corto ustedes lo saben el tiempo en
televisión pero yo les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros aquí haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 haber expuesto los puntos de
vista en torno a lo que está sucediendo
allí en medio oriente y sobre todo sobre
el conflicto palestino israelí les
agradezco también mucho la sintonía a
ustedes les recuerdo que la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Keyla
maestre y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera siga con
nosotros siga en sintonía de France 24
[Música]